so what was the outcome of the divorce
when the dust settled right like when
the process was done like what were you
left with what was she left with how are
you treated how was she treated okay so
during the so after
like
this happens in november so i
begged her for six weeks
because we were together for
thanksgiving and christmas and she was
faking it the whole time not to let the
kids know that we were getting a divorce
nobody knew
we were sleeping in the same bed but i
was negotiating with her the whole time
i was like oh that's you know let's go
to counseling let's do something else
because neither one of us were cheating
we didn't have any uh significant others
and i had no idea the depth that she had
already studied this out
and i always tell guys like women plan
this out well in advance i mean three
years you know you might be hearing this
right now and thinking guys wow three
years that's you know it's pretty it's
it's not that uncommon
and um thanks for saying that uh
rich
it's uh
keeping that that perspective so
i for up until around christmas and i
remember just i couldn't even sleep i
couldn't figure out if way do any way to
bring any new business in because then
all the numbers start going through my
head it's like i'm a small family
construction business
if i
i know i i talk to my accountant right
away and i say hey
if i
go to half
do i have the leverage to go borrow like
i used to he said no
i said so that means it's going to
severely limit the size and the amount
of jobs i can get it goes yeah
that's right
not only you're being set back the money
you have but you're being set back the
money you could possibly make
and i'm sweating in bed and i'm i'm
going well how do i bring in new
business right now
i'm assuming you don't care about that
though right oh no yeah and and in fact
she just at one point we had one
empty lot left back up in oakland now we
lived in san luis obispo people don't
know where those are geographically it's
about four hour car drive
in oakland in the middle city san
francisco
and san luis obispo it's this beautiful
bucolic coastal town it's like
oprah winfrey one day said it's the best
place to live in the world the happiest
place in the world to live
so
it's just gorgeous you know it's rolling
hills it looks like something out of
fairy tale
and
i um
i was having to go back and forth
between these two places to
to
keep up
enough
income because it was after the 2008
recession
just barely keeping ends meet
keeping them together
and
and then
so this was like yeah three four years
later after that economy was just
starting to sputter back up
and
i
negotiated with her for about
two months
and then one day
i said hey you realize
if you take
all these properties
i'm not going to be able to make a
living like i used to
so we should just split
the assets
and i put together a package that i
thought was fair
where actually she ended up with about
sixty percent i then ended up forty
percent she would end up with the income
properties that i ended up with the
properties that maybe had a little more
equity that the potential to make more
and we call it even she was like oh no
no no no
you owe me
i said but you've been my partner all
these years because
no
i don't i here's and here's a big thing
even though she would work with me and
advise me and which was true
she wasn't on the payroll
she would claim housewife
on our taxes
okay
that was a big deal
she wasn't
architect and we would hire other
architects to sign the so it was
theoretically true now she was huge in
you know we would we'd look at a piece
of property hey you think we should buy
that lot yeah i think so
okay then what are we going to put on it
i think you should put nine apartments
on it okay why didn't you put it on
payroll though for tax savings reasons
to lower your tax brackets no it's the
other way around you get a bigger ride
off on a housewife oh okay in california
yeah
and uh
part of it
yeah but part of it is that then i think
i think it's uh she's not you know
she did for the first while but then for
the last the pre then for the next day
so the previous eight years housewife in
the first 10 years she was on payroll
and you guys were married for more than
10 years right over 20 yeah 20. okay
we were together 22. i called 22 because
from the time i met her which was just
boom all the way
in california i think it's after 10
years you're you're on the hook for
alimony you're on forever forever yeah
forever
so
she said at that moment she goes no you
owe me and i was like i owe you yeah we
didn't leave a bargaining position on
this one oh yeah we've been sleeping in
the same bed for all this time we've
been
we've been
you know we go to the same we're doing
everything together we're in the same
room we're in the same house we don't
how could i one person know another
we've had the same experience now let's
take the assets and split them and move
forward i said you you're a smart lady
you know you're a
hardcore feminist
you know and i said strong right
so true and i was
and she said
well
look
if it's going to be a problem
it may be a you may have a hard time
getting to know your kids
wow
i was like
oh [ __ ]
you have to bleep that out i'm sorry but
but i
was floored and i had been talking to
other guys i talked to some lawyers i
talked to
you know people by that time and they
were very clear they said look
if those kind of threats start coming up
she's got way bigger plans and
don't
get caught
you're gonna you're gonna
she wants you in jail
and she knew my buttons to push you know
i had a i never i'd never been arrested
i don't have any tickets i'd never been
to jail i'd never been in
you know i barely even had a speeding
ticket
um
but
i had you know i would i i'd get mad i
and when i was a kid you know you talk
about fighting stuff when we were in
high school i'd fight
but i never hit anybody after that but
she
had this
i realized then
she had this dialogue that somehow i was
scary
later it would come up in depositions
she kept claiming i she was scared and i
was scary
did this lead up to a false tv
yeah
okay so those of you that don't know
what a fuss tv is and i talk about it in
my book in the chapter on why smart men
don't marry did you read my book by the
way
i did yeah just got done with it yeah go
ahead would you would you uh co-sign
that chat oh absolutely
i was sitting there i had to like stop
the car and sit there listen you're just
nodding your head going yeah there it is
and i've heard it i've studied enough
about this i've heard it in other places
but you you you portray it perfectly so
go for it dude you wrote it then so
women use this as a trump card often um
terrible women so let me just be clear
on that because
it doesn't require any proof and
what they'll so i'll tell you a story so
this one guy was telling me that you
know he had come home from work he's
expecting to see his you know his family
and his kids
and as he walks in the front door
um his wife is basically on the phone
with the police saying
we're really scared you know he's
threatening to hurt us he has guns and
all this sort of stuff and it's like
15 minutes later two cruisers rip down
the street one of them parks on his
front lawn tearing up like shrubs and
stuff another one in the driveway sirens
going and he basically gets hauled away
in handcuffs um they change the lock
locks on the house and he doesn't have
access to the house his kids when the
house sells nothing because she claimed
he was a bad scary man he was a boogie
man and bad things you know were
happening um they don't require any
proof it's just
the allegation is plenty in most places
in the world um
wayne went through that so what happened
with the false tv charts like what did
she do so here's how it went down
i realized when she said that
that i was like don't wait a minute
those are not her normal words because
i've been living with this person for 22
years so i'm very aware of when she's
saying something threatening because
i've seen her deal with a lot of people
she she handled a lot of our legal work
or at least set the strategy for our if
we had issues or whatever you know
with as you do in business just in
business
and very crafty very clever and by the
way she came from a family
very broken family where her father
destroyed her mother in divorce in the
late 70s in california
so her mother
went from being the happy housewife
like leave it to beaver to having to
become an oncology nurse changing
bedpans in the middle of the night over
a two-year period
and she was 17 at the time when this
happened her dad was
the
ceo
of a fortune 500 company known as
western microwave
and they make bombs
for the military
so now consider
a man's
you know state of mind a guy who
last year your bomb killed 400 people
out of whack got to do better this year
you got to kill 500.
so
this
uh to to continue to keep him
peaking at this he would read books is
the standard fair that he would talk
about was the art of war
and his daughters he had three daughters
i married one of them this is what they
talk around about around the coffee
table
and i didn't know anything about this i
was a deering woods man i i grew up
just
being a simple damn builder guy and i
wanted to surf and sail and have a good
time yeah you're a surfing hippie right
yeah i was
and oh when you see my video if you look
at my video on vitruvian built
you're going to see a guy who looks
nothing like me now i even look older
then we're gonna get to hopefully get to
that so
all right so
she
when she started talking about this
about me not seeing the kids i was like
this is a huge red flag now
i have it's been three months now i have
you didn't know why at the time but like
the spidey senses were tingling like
hang on what's coming down the pipes
here i said hang on a second the kids
weren't home i walked in the house
i packed a bag i came back out i got in
the car and i left okay
we
and and and i and a month before i'd
even asked her because as soon as as
soon as she told me about this divorce
thing weird mail starts showing up i
mean like within the next couple days
she started signing up for
like singles not singles dating stuff
but things that
that women who are single would get in
the mail like you know special bank
accounts and you know bus tax strategy
planning and and these things that we
would never
look at if we were a married couple and
i started noticing this mail i said wait
a minute you had to plan this for a
while
like this didn't just happen yesterday
it got hit the road running right i mean
there's always a
fan left in the hourglass you know she's
only gonna look for so long
yeah oh
and then as soon as even during the
divorce process man she went out she got
full work over from forehead to to [ __ ]
put the whole thing worked over
i saw her later in court her face a
little bit deformed she landed herself a
wealthy guy now it's another story but
but she worked it hard yeah it spent
some money there and she's a good
looking lady too she always was and she
never lost it really so
but at one point i was like
i said we haven't touched each other in
months
i go what are we doing i go are we
dating others i mean do you you go out
all the time and i'm separate she goes
i don't care what you do i said really
she goes yeah i don't give a [ __ ] we're
done
now we just have to exercise this out as
efficiently as we can to retain as much
of the wealth as we can and not [ __ ]
this up
i was like okay
so i didn't start dating
but i was like in my mind that's like oh
okay so we're done just we can date
others
and um so i left and there was a woman
who i knew and i called her up asked her
for a ride from where i flew to in the
airport i really just wanted to get away
and she picked me up and i'd never
touched her before and i asked her i
said can we hang out like you know she's
single woman she's like yeah for sure so
we started hanging out we had a good
time and she knew i was just coming out
of this divorce
and and uh well my ex ended up having
a guy follow us
take pictures and she gave that to my
kids later
um even after
nice yeah to
juice them up a little more yeah
so anyway that happened but
so what happened afterwards okay so dv
so okay so i'm out of the house
she
puts a big pile of [ __ ] in a uh
she puts it in my hanger
my airplane hand she purges everything
out of the house that she thinks is mine
which is just my clothes some skis some
sports care
and she dumps it in the hangar
so i'm looking at all the stuff
okay
and there was a pair of my daughter's
skis in there
so one day
i drove by the house
i was gonna put the skis not even on the
property
but at the front
uh
mailbox well she happened to be out
there and i live on this big estate 10
acres out in the country
the kids were kind of up the driveway
and i said here
i ended up with these these are madison
she says
maddie was 18 by this time just turning
18.
and she says
you're not you know get the hell out of
here i don't want to see you and yelling
at me and i yelled at her back
just had
words i never i didn't even step on the
property i was on the street
and i got in the car and i was huff and
huff and i was pissed off and i drove
away
she went to the judge the next day and
said
he came at me and i was scared to death
and boom restraining order
yeah i can't be near my kids i can't be
near the house i can't now and then and
then was finally we got to the first day
of hearing
okay so now now she wants to ask for a
decisional hearing by the judge i don't
know what you call it exactly but
so we end up from judge and i have a
lawyer by this time
she walks in and makes spends about
three hours on the stand telling
the judge
why
she should have a hundred percent
management control of the company that
we've had together for 22 years
and i was just sitting there
shell shocked i was listening to her
did you ever think for a minute that
that he would give it to her or you're
like oh this isn't going to happen just
let her you know no [ __ ] way yeah no
way i kept looking at my lawyer like
what
now it came to halftime and she threw
all kinds of allegations about it and
she even said oh by the way
if i get control of this company i have
every qualification to run it
i am you know i have a degree in
architecture and i've been
this partner for 22 years and i've i you
know i used to be
pound nails and i know how to order the
concrete truck and
by the way yeah
i have three guys who have agreed to put
their license up if he leaves
and he she named him
and one of the guys i mean i knew of all
three of them
um
and one was friends of her dad another
guy was at some random dude and another
guy was a friend of like the family
and um
and i just sat down and i was like
really
those guys could do my job i mean i i by
this time i'd even gotten a patent
and i've gotten i was start i was
lecturing on the college level
about
building technology i'm considered a
building technologist that's the name
so i would talk to architecture students
and
engineering students and i would talk to
green um um you know uh he call uh
what's the word in college
um
but the greenies and so
uh
i
had you know i was like really this is
all going to replace me
okay
and then i went to lunch they broke for
lunch and i called my accountant
and i can he had just been through a
gnarly divorce that took him
four years and he had finished this and
he was my partner for 25 years
because we owned a lot of
income properties together but i
another part of what i did is i had put
together syndications
and raised money and we
uh bought apartment buildings all over
california it was very successful we did
really well with that and
so my accountant was my partner in that
and i told him hey this is what's going
on he goes don't worry this is just
d-day it's gonna get better from here
and
and um
i said well
do
i even want this company
and he was like
well just go in there and give it your
best shot
okay so i go back
yeah
i go back and then i say look your honor
so you march back into the
slaughterhouse yeah
like and my and my lawyer actually
looked at me and said the same thing he
goes because you know i don't really
know you that well because we're just
starting this process like i may have
known him a couple weeks and he'd seen
my numbers i thought it was just going
to be a matter of just like saying okay
here's here's the assets
who gets what
and let's go from there
that's what i thought it was going to be
she turns it into
she wants full management control and i
was like
well
how is that going to work and so i told
the judge i said look your honor
i
don't understand how this can even be a
thing because we've been partners for 22
years
and we've made every decision together
and now we're going to be at odds with
each other and one guy is going to tell
the other guy what to do
like that sounds like a recipe for
disaster
so
so he hands over control
within two days he writes a letter says
she's got all control so then first
thing so she's got the kids she's got
the assets she's got the house which
you've moved out of now she's got the
business
yep
and so
now i was in the middle of building out
a handful of projects which i really
wanted to finish
um
and
i uh
actually one of the houses was for a guy
named dr cherry
and he
was now okay i'm gonna take you back 10
years and this is kind of interesting
especially for a lot of guys
in america and california
around the 10-year mark of marriage she
and i were arguing a lot
about where we should live she wanted to
stay in the city she wanted to be the
cool city girl and i wanted to see
what's a coincidence that at the 10-year
mark where she knows that you're on the
hook for lifelong alimony that she
became a little more disagreeable
oh there's no question
she knew what she had i knew what she
had i i'm no dummy you know i i knew it
was a mistake but
you know we had a great life we even we
were living in oakland
we
you know
we were
i wasn't super rich but
i did good you know and i wake up every
morning and have jobs to do and very
well respected and we would
help build the little elementary school
in our town and
all the good stuff you know
and kids all running around all the time
and um
so
oh i kind of lost my train of thought we
were um you're you're talking about 10
years back with this guy that you had to
build oh yeah okay
so so
because we're arguing
she wants to go see a shrink
go
couples counsel
okay
so we go and
turns in she she convinces them that i
have the problem
and i'm
sorry i'm not laughing at you i'm just
it's like see i was right again but yeah
go ahead yeah i have the problem i have
the problem because i'm angry because i
was like look we got 10 million bucks
how much more can we you know just let's
just put that in a freaking simple six
percent thing or even ten or we don't
put in anything we own properties i mean
they're spitting out cash and
it's like we could we don't need to have
a second and third house if we just have
our one house and then there all the
time and i always was gonna put my
moniker of success to myself was that i
get to see my house in the daytime
because i work from before sunrise to
after sunset every morning i'd wake up
at six i'd be the first one down at the
lumber yard make sure everybody's gonna
have enough materials
yeah
and then when i come home at night and
oh once a while we have a little fun at
sneak home because i live very close to
all my jobs you know you get a little
nooky in the afternoon that was fun it
was great you know and and uh
and then we get to go um
on three day vacations to the mountain
house and once in a while we take off
for two weeks and go to things it was
great you know it's like
but
but at 10 years i was like
[Music]
how much more do we need
and let's do some different things let's
go explore the world i haven't i haven't
seen the rest of the world i haven't
seen europe i want to do this when my
kids are small
and that's when the resistance started
and i was like what is going on so she
said we gotta you're not happy
you we gotta go see a shrink
so we went together
and then after a while
she was like you know i'm just
frustrated trying to explain to this guy
and to her why we should do this now
and i probably wasn't the best
communicator
whatever
they convinced me i should go on prozac
i
yeah and i did not want
i was like
i'm not depressed
i'm pissed
[Laughter]
i just want to go on a sailboat from
time to time man that's my medicine i
don't need these pills well yeah well i
wanted to park all the jobs we have and
take the kids and introduce something oh
god yeah totally but but instead you got
put on like antidepressants right
because you're
you know
you know imagine that you're married
you've done the right thing your entire
life you've raised a family you've built
a business you're loaded you've got a
plane you've got multiple houses you got
vacation houses and it's like you just
want to sail the boat and and you go to
a therapist and the guy's like here take
these pills and shut up
dude i wasn't even asking for life i was
asking for a year yeah one year i said
listen let's just go for a [ __ ]
you